salut c'est bill donne pour bru dessus
physionomiste en boîte de nuit depuis
une quinzaine d'années je vais donner
quelques conseils pour éviter de se
faire recaler en boîte de nuit
les mecs arrivent bourré en boîte de
nuit c'est comme si tu allais en
restaurant avec ton assiette
logiquement le reste ne va pas de faire
entrer puisqu'ils vendent la bouffe nous
on vend de l'alcool c'est arrive déjà
déférents boîte de nuit
concrètement on sait qu'on peut pas te
vendre grand-chose à monter une blague
car dès qu'on profite de toi mais là
c'est autre chose
moi ça je déconnais
[Musique]
quand vous venez en groupe essayez
d'être sûr de tout le monde dit vaut
mieux qu'aujourd'hui en 2019 les physios
sont sans pitié et 6 sur 15 personnes y
en a un qui correspond pas il se peut
que personne ne soit coupée en général
on est un petit peu plus subtil en
suivant sucré trois ou quatre pour
pâques et une personne en particulier
qui sentent visés parce que sinon
forcément c'est vexant les gens qui se
présentent en disant j'ai un pote qui à
l'intérieur dis toi bien une chose si
ton pote est rentré sans toi c'est qu'il
savait qu'il n'allait pas rentrer avec
toi donc plutôt que d'insulter physio
insulter votre pote qui rentrait sans
vous
on dit souvent la nuit l'argent ça tu
achète des vêtements mais pas du style
le style tu l'as où tu l'as pas mais
pour ceux qui n'ont pas la même chez
merck on sait que je puisse vous donner
c'est d'aller dans des boutiques tout
simple et regarder comment les
mannequins sont habillés mais oubliez
les marques style j'aime pas cités n'ont
donc les marques où il ya trop de flou
trop diamant les marques ou ça brille
c'est pas parce qu'une veste coûte vingt
mille euros qu'elle est forcément mieux
ou plus stylé qu'une veste qui coûte 50
euros
très honnêtement en général les gens qui
achètent des marques sont des gens qui
n'ont pas beaucoup qui n'ont pas de
connaissances de la mode et qui achète
juste parce que ça coûte cher et parce
que ça les fait se sentir spéciale les
gens qui connaissent la mode n'ont pas
besoin de marque pour pour briller après
il faut avoir du style mais du style ça
veut rien dire est ce que moi j'ai du
style finalement moins tout cas j'ai
hunting qui ne correspond à moi c'est à
vous de savoir où est ce que vous allez
aller et comment les gens l'habitude de
s'habiller mais le mieux c'est de rester
fidèle à soi-même
bon admettons t passe-t-il t'as pas
d'argent tu te trouves pas très beau et
il ya un rien vraiment pour aller ton
côté et c'est le moins d'avoir un sens
de l'humour si tu arrives avec une bonne
blague ta grande chance de rentrer moi
j'en ai qu ils m'ont fait j'ai même des
mecs qui m'ont fait des tours de magie
et s'est passé quasiment à chaque fois
mais par contre ta blague l'intérêt
sacrément bonne parce que on est des
connards non c'est rigolo quand même une
fois que tu as le style et à tous qu'il
faut finalement et 13 plus que
l'attitude l'attitude c'est aussi très
important
tu peux être la personne la plus belle
de la terre la fille la plus belle de la
terre le mec le pistil la terre si tu
arrives en faisant la gueule ou 11 ans
le mec vénère c'est pas la peine
si tu arrives tu es manière arrogante en
pensant et une verge et on perd c'est
pas la peine
si tu arrives en pensant qu'on était
esclave et une odeur zone ii tarde
trouvera le cordon c'est pas la peine tu
peux arriver souriant un petit peu
confirmé pas trop à toi juste de savoir
trouver la bonne chose parce que si
jamais c'est trop c'est non et si c'est
pas assez
un mec qui arrivait careca robe de se
présenter aux loisirs il ya un truc
bizarre alors il faut savoir que chaque
quartier a ses codes et chaque club de
chaque quartier a ses codes
donc du coup ça va me ce que tu évites
dans un endroit que tu as vu dans un
autre endroit déjà le movie peuvent faut
l'éviter
quant à une perte de balle donnée parce
qu'on a horreur de ça faut il faut dire
que chaque physio et même chaque club a
un ego à débloquer propre à lui donc si
tu te crois plus important parce que tu
rentres ailleurs sachant que fait la
personne face à toi pense que son club
est le meilleur
de tte façon tu as tout faux et a des
chances d'être recalé
à partir du moment où on dit non c'est
non ça sert à rien d'insister c'est non
et on reviendra pas dessus moi il ne me
répond préféré un port de moins de nuit
c'est les gens lorsque tous les refuges
qui disent ça va j'ai pas une tête de
voyous une tête de terroristes ça fait à
peu près 15 ans travaille en boîte de
nuit je sais toujours pas qu'est ce que
c'est avoir une tête de voyous une tête
de terroristes et il est quelques
personnes que j'ai refusé qu'ils ont
tenté de me donner une explication très
souvent on fait une description physique
qui me correspondait vachement donc un
conseil ne vous aventurez surtout pas
sur ce terrain là quand on vous refuse
trouve autre chose ou du train des fois
le silence est bien mieux
si j'avais un conseil je ne voudrais je
ne vous dirai pas choisir un style mais
choisir une période
il ya des périodes qui sont très
propices pour rentrer en boîte de nuit
halloween c'est le sort de l'année où
tout le monde de rentrer en boîte de
nuit
si tu te fait recaler jour d'halloween
c'est vraiment inquiétant tu as juste à
déguiser et à moitié mais pas de masque
parce qu'un masque on va me demander de
les enlever
et si ta tête et c'est site incite à la
tête d'un homme et rica ou si tu as une
tête de quelqu'un qu'on connaît pas on
fera pas entraîner cité maquiller de la
tête aux pieds
ça se verra pas tu passeras partout et
il ya un autre moment de l'année où
c'est propice pour que tout le monde
puisse rentrer en boîte de nuit
c'est la fashion week et on assiste dans
l'année donc tu as de quoi faire j'ai à
dire comment est ce que c'est possible
de rentrer en fashion week en boîte de
nuit alors que c'est censé être là
qu'ils allaient soirée de marque
laiteries privées etc
si tu regardes bien les mecs de la mode
aujourd'hui en 2019 s'habille comme les
mecs de cités de quand j'étais jeune
c'est à dire au début des années 90 donc
si tu sors ton vieux jogging à khost est
un vieux jogging tacchini tu mets une
paire d re max une paire de tel ou
encore pire une paire de requins
crois moi que si tu baragouine un peu en
anglais et tu as une petite charge tas
de très fortes chances de rentrer
partout en boîte de nuit parce qu'un mec
qui se dégage qui se pointent à une
porte de bois denis avec ce style sorti
des années 90 totalement dégueulasse
dont même moi je m'habille et pas comme
ça à l'époque et qui au sein aujourd'hui
on va se dire ce mec là est trop sûr de
lui donc on va le faire entrer